eigentlich sollte es im tv duell von
kamala harris und vize präsident mike
pence heute nacht in amerika um die
große politik gehen aber der wahre star
der show ist diese freche fliege während
mike pence über rassismus in amerika
debattiert setzt sich der brummer auf
das weiße hauptteil des vize-präsidenten
eine ganze weile bleibt er sitzen macht
es sich richtig gemütlich dem
demokratischen
präsidentschaftskandidaten joe biden
entgeht das natürlich nicht
er twittert noch während die debatte im
gange ist spenden sie fünf dollar um
seine kampagne zum fliegen zu bringen
innerhalb von wenigen minuten
überschlagen sich die kommentare zum
insekt auf mike pence kopf die fliege
wird zum symbol für den us
amerikanischen wahlkampf dass sie so
einen riesigen auftritt hat damit hätte
diese fliege wohl auch nicht gerechnet
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dir hier das nächste
video an und vergessen nicht zu
abonnieren